type of hate has to be manufactured in
the head of a man for him to stand over
a 6-year-old boy and stab him 26 times
the suspect's wife told detectives he
listened to conservative talk radio and
thought the mother and son would have
people over to attack them he apparently
had been listening to conservative radio
for some time Joe listens to
conservative talk radio on a regular
basis and has been heavily interested in
the events that have recently occurred
in Israel she also said he was concerned
about the national day of jihad and
wanted Shaheen and her son to move out
Alum we're here at the
janaza of the young six-year-old Muslim
boy who was stabbed 26 times stabb in
him more than 26 times and he was
looking in his eyes here with some of
the community leaders I'm still trying
to wrap my mind around this the suspect
knocked on the door to her room in their
shared planfield home and started an
argument about the Israel Hamas War then
attacked her with a large knife she she
reported that she fought him off and hid
in the bathroom but could hear the
suspect stabbing her son from another
room as she called police this child
that we just buried W was about to go to
school today on Monday but instead he
was brought here to the
cemetery uh this MBA This calamity is
not only limited to uh his family it's
not only limited to uh uh Muslims or
Palestinians this could happen to any
one of us could happen to me and my wife
could happen to you could happen to our
neighbors uh we have uh to stand all
together in this very uh difficult time
to um uh stand for peace and justice for
all children and all free people uh in
everywhere uh the message of hate uh
should stop immediately and uh be
replaced with a message of uh peace and
Justice because without Justice and
again we always talk about peace but
peace and justice has to go together
without Justice um it will be very
difficult to enjoy any peace and so um
uh as an American Muslim uh who stand
for the values of uh uh justice and
peace uh I ask everybody to uh join us
in protecting our uh our families and
our children uh to enjoy uh uh our lives
here but also to uh stand for justice
and peace for uh people in Gaza and
people everywhere because uh as uh Mar
King said uh Injustice anywhere is a
threat to Justice everywhere and this is
what we're facing now it doesn't stop
with just the uh six-year-old boy you
have you just telling me the mother also
got stabbed 12 timesing the stabbing
death of a six-year-old Muslim boy this
happened over the weekend to in a suburb
south of Chicago tonight police are
saying that boy and his mother were
targeted because of the war in Israel I
want to show you this right here with
Dia alumi just turned 6 years old a
couple weeks ago on Saturday the
Sheriff's Office says the family's
71-year-old landlord Joseph subba
attacked the boy and his mother the boy
was stabbed 26 times his mother stabbed
over a dozen times he knocked on the
door and that he attempted to choke her
and said you Muslims must die and
attempted to stab her and stabbed her
the crime confirming for many in the
Palestinian American Community the fear
that's been building since the start of
the war and what they call an atmosphere
of hate it pains me that the sacrificial
lamb to this atmosphere was this
beautiful young six-year-old boy who had
his whole life ahead of him among those
paying their respects Chicago mayor
Brandon Johnson Governor JB pritsker and
Congressman Jonathan Jackson yeah and my
heart goes out to her because she's the
one that's most affected from all of us
I mean she witnessed what happened to
her son he was stabbed 26 times the
knife still in his belly when he was
taking to the autopsy she herself was
stabbed 12 times including in her face
she can't talk and she she's in you know
basically very serious condition in the
hospital and on top of it top of the
physical injury the mental trauma she's
alone in the hospital without this kind
of community support right now because
of security reasons and health reasons
so we have to remember her uh we're
trying to raise some money to assist her
with her hospital bills and everything
else but she's in a very strong very a
place where no one can Envy her and I
just want to add you know we've said a
lot about this but I'll say one more
point you know as I was standing today
and looking at the thousands of people
that were there um the dozens of
Television cameras from all over the
United States and the world we had the
governor we had the mayor we had you
know this elected official that elected
official and I thought to myself how is
our beautiful martyr our beautiful boy
wedia any different from all of the
wadas all of the beautiful Martyrs in
Gaza the 750 of them he was stabbed in a
heinous crime yes but I ask you do you
think a bomb that falls from the
sky does less damage than a knife that
stabs 12 or 26 times do you think that's
a pretty image because it isn't so what
is it about this situation that woke up
the conscience of our governor and our
mayor and our
media we have to understand there is no
difference between this heinous crime
here which we all must condemn and
clearly everybody gets that and the
manyas and this is the father's feeling
this is not just me he said my son is a
represent ation of what is happening and
to feel for him we have to feel for
everyone so I say to them can you get
your your Humanity your intellect to
understand that what you see close to
home and you feel it isn't any different
if it's a little far away and we are
contributing we're not just not feeling
what's happening we're contributing $8
billion warships you know more moral
support media support to what's
happening so I'll just close by saying
you know this boy has gone but not in
vain he is is waking up the conscience
of everyone around us and we need to
keep that message and may Allah accept
him you know as a bird of
Heaven these places obviously as the was
saying
U that these are sacred places the
graveyard is is a is a place that we
have to observe certain sanctities but
um I think that you know the ending is
all the same which is at the end of the
day when you put people in the ground
when the grave is all covered it all
looks the same but we know from our Dean
that the stories under those graves are
very different and we pray that Allah
subhana tala first and foremost accept
as as a Shah as a martyr and that the
cruelty that he faced in this life uh is
met with the mercy of Allah subhana wa
tala in the next and that all he faces
now is the expanse of Allah's Garden I
often think about when I see these
tragic situations because we've had a
lot of them over the years um those that
we know and and those that we don't know
but we love and we we certainly make Dua
for I think of
Asia when the dropped the uh the stone
on her and as she was being tortured she
laughed and spoke about her as as a mad
woman and mocked her but uh Allah showed
her her place in Jenna when she was
struck now now I think what we have to
balance as Muslims is both the The Hope
in Allah's Mercy when these situations
happen that we know that Allah subhana
waala your lord does not forget your
lord Allah does not let the reward of
the good doers go to waste nor does
Allah let the crimes of the criminals go
unpunished so we have to sort of balance
our outrage with what has happened in
the material world with the hope that
what Allah subhana T offers in the
afterlife and that which is immaterial
to us right now or what we can't sense
and perceive right now uh is greater and
is restorative and I want to say you
know we've been talking about Palestine
people need to see the stories people
need to hear the stories people need to
see the human The Human Side of these
babies uh one W can be more effective in
waking up the conscience of people than
a number 800 900 Allah knows what it
will be by the time we by the time we
leave the cemetery one would the Earth
can be more effective uh in waking up
the conscience of people and we hope
that that will be the case in and so
it's important to just remember that
these are kids that they have stories
that they have families um part of the
the way that we maybe unintentionally
become a part of the dehumanization as
we only show charred burned uh you know
uh corpses and we don't tell stories and
our Quran is full of the stories of
people that uh have have have full
stories of Dua and pain and and and and
victory after defeat so we need to tell
their stories with and then we need to
ask
to make our story a good one and let our
ending be good I remind everyone um you
know it's very hard when you when when
you kind of witness the
Unspeakable um to speak that's why it's
called the
Unspeakable but what distinguishes US is
that we have IM we have faith we believe
in Allah and we believe in the
Hereafter you believe in Allah and you
believe in a paradise and you believe
that every single one of these every
single one of these Souls is in a better
place
so while you try to fight back on the
hell on Earth that's being created for
them here have faith that Allah will
admit them into the paradise that we all
hope to go bid the
nighttime you can
see the power of the propaganda media
pushing lies one 40 babies were beheaded
this is completely false no evidence has
been provided for this the claim comes
from this journalist during a Walkin
talk she makes the claim saying I see in
the distance more bodies being covered
babies their heads cut off later in a
tweet however she admits that she did
not see bodies but heard a soldier
talking
about why because they are the ones
planning to commit atrocities themselves
to do this they need to convince you
that Palestinians are barbaric animals
that rape torture and behead babies
pushing the
dehumanization of the Muslims and this
is the direct result
of that so we need our friends our
brothers and sisters in humanity those
who are out there that have God
Consciousness
who have a heart who can put themselves
in this situation you have
children you have an obligation to speak
up to speak to your community so this
doesn't spread like a
cancer and more people don't follow the
footsteps of one evil man you notice his
religion is not mentioned imagine if
this was flipped again we hear we know
how the scenario goes but we don't blame
the religion we blame the individual and
then we got to look to the hate
provocator Joe listens to conservative
talk radio on a regular basis and has
been heavily interested in the events
that have recently occurred in Israel
she also said he was concerned about the
national day of jihad those who are
pushing and pedaling much of this hate
this atrocity
propaganda we urge the media to exercise
responsibility and balance its reporting
recognizing that it plays a pivotal role
in shaping public perception who
promotes debunked
lies as in the case of the beheaded
Israeli
children and when you have a
media supposedly mainstream
media that also refers to debunked lies
as in the case of rabing Israeli woman I
have seen children under the
rebble I have seen
children Torn to Pieces from War I have
never thought I will see this here in
America I have never thought I will see
this barbaric action here in our
land and our hearts ache because of that
because we as me as a physician I have
never imagined that we will lose our
Humanity to that degree and treat
children where we are supposed to heal
them and take care of them saying that
we reject hate we reject discrimination
and we stand for one playing field for
all one America for
all sorry it's a
little it's kind of thrown me off a
little bit cuz I have a five and a halfy
old she'd be in the same class and
it's my wife and I have been talking
about it all weekend and we couldn't
couldn't
imagine
so honestly forget the politics I don't
care about the politics I'm getting sick
and tired of this crap going on around
the country in the State
anywhere kids are kids let kids be
kids hold people accountable make sure
that this doesn't happen anywhere else
too much has happened throughout this
country too much hate and I think about
my daughter all the time and this is you
want to think that this is an isolated
situation but there's there's so much
hate out there and we need to stop from
everywhere
alaykum I have no doubt that it will be
a successful project inshallah I've had
the blessing of knowing brother Eddie
since he started the dean show and he's
one of the most sincere and most
dedicated people to the DA that I have
ever met so please do support the dean
[Music]
Center I cannot leave without giving you
a gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tune in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum